hey guys it is time for a brand-new
exclusive Collider interview and I am
very excited about this one because you
guys might know not this year but the
year before I was lucky enough to host
the impulse panel at San Diego comic-con
and it was a dream come true because one
it's a good show
that was a bucket list item for me and
also the cast was a pleasure like the
star of the show Maddie Hasson hi hi
what everybody didn't see before is
there was a minor mishap but you were
smiling the I told you I belted I'm also
proud of you thank you I wouldn't be
able to do that the only person that
says that to me after these shows is my
mom yeah oh it's nice to have that
support coming from another place in
your mind
give me your mom's number my mom would
love impulse really I know yeah my mom
is very into just like anything
entertainment
my mom might not want me to say my mom
is very in tune with all pop culture
movies and shows and I feel like
something like this is right up her
alley because it's super entertaining
it's got a whole lot of depth and
seriously a freaking fantastically
performance I can't applaud you enough I
mean wasn't it amazing what if I was
like yeah Wow but it really it really is
I asked why how old your mom is is I'm
getting like a lot of men in there like
30s
30 to 40 range that like loved the show
that to me sounds like it could be the
jumper movie of Doug of it the doug
liman that's it
yeah it's actually an interesting thing
and like whatever you show on YouTube -
right but before I have thought about
that I was like what what I was like
this is not right and then I was like
this is really great because it I mean
you guys need to know about this yeah I
forgotten teenage girls experience and
you know the whole and quality content
should appeal to everybody maybe not
super young viewers for this but but
when you're of a certain age it's a good
way to spend your time it's
answered this season well one there's
one censored version this season so
there's less I think I noticed that I
watched one episode and I think it was a
few say it was censoring some of the
curse words yeah I just caught me by
surprise I know I prefer the uncensored
version not that I'm like sitting and
watching myself 24 hours a day but I I
would rather people see it the way
Watchmen today no I've seen the first
episode of both seasons but I haven't
seen the rest I would I would be like
the I've seen the trailers and the you
know but I I'm too critical I think I
wonder cuz like I think about that a lot
when we do our shows I don't have to
review something unless I've said
something that I need to you can't
imagine it what add to well also I feel
the same way about interviews I'm like I
can't watch them I'm so why would I ever
say that it makes you feel better I
won't rewatch this but I'll share it
with everybody and everyone's going to
see it and it's like now you've joined
the bang Club so you're ready to be
overly critical of your hair even though
Emma phenomenal right now so but we were
talking before I'm looking in the video
thing and they're too long right now I'm
working on a movie and I've been off for
like two weeks and I'm not allowed to
cut them on my own
so I've been waiting you've been working
with James Wan haven't you you know he's
one of my favorite human beings in this
industry what a delight have you you've
met him I was actually I was I've met
him a couple of times but one of my
favorite things as I was on the set of
the conjuring the first conjuring when
it's been like 2012 or something yeah
and it's just it's wild watching the
first conjuring before he was like a big
deal saw came before that so he already
had we already saw and some other
projects so he had a name but the
conjuring was like a genre game-changer
recently he's so lovely he is he's such
a lovely man do I dare ask you if you're
allowed to tell us anything about your
role in them at all do you do do you
like horror and stuff like that does any
of that bother you on set no not on set
because it it's like demystified you
know what I mean but watching it before
I like journeyed into this
thing I was like oh and then like weeks
leading up to the project I was like I
guess I should get into horror so I
watched a bunch of stuff and it's you
know I've sort of DS sense okay yeah
it's kind of like lessened for you the
fear of fact yeah but I'm still a baby
why do you laugh after I remember what
did I watch watch The Shining
oh yeah that's a must I want what I want
is the one where the girl gets raped by
a tree oh it's Evil Dead what the hell
did you watch the first Evil Dead and no
other evil Dead's I watched a very old
version and I was like why did nobody
cuz a friend recommended it he was like
this is a great movie and then it
happened and I was like whoa whoa whoa
and I was like oh my god it's happening
for real and there was like a branch it
just gently cups her breasts he like
tried to make this rape scene sexy and I
was like what the [ __ ] is going on not
allowed to swear I remind you Claire I
was high in [ __ ] going on what's
happening here so you should probably go
and also watch Evil Dead 2 an army of
Darkness which are so different from the
first
okay but then the tree rapey scene gets
even more horrific in the 2013 remake
but is it I what I cuz I didn't like
obviously when was the first one made
like the 60s 1880 80s um they need to be
thinking about the shining I think
that's the shining day too
they try to look like sexy close enough
you know what I mean and I was like this
sucks a little so if it's not sexy and
the later for if it's like a real you
know what I mean
portrayal it's it's dark okay it's some
dark stuff I don't know what I will dive
in why not okay what else am I gonna do
anytime you have lots to do with your
time you're very busy right now so
that's not even the only upcoming movie
you have what's the one that you just
had the plate at Fantastic Fest oh we
some in the darkness cuz you're your co
cast and that makes me very happy
we're a big we're big fans of Alexandra
Daddario here and I love Amy because
channel zero is one of my fit there's
good genre material for you but her
season in channel zero season to no end
house is excellent she's amazing she
really is such a good actress I was
supposed to do a movie with her but I
ended up not working out but she I mean
she
I think she's incredible used to do
another one with her and I was like oh
damn
there's so many many more opportunity I
know I saw that I just think the world
of her and Alexander I think they're
both I can't wait to scar that one it's
so fun I can I love I watched that movie
twice and I was like ah the second time
I was like I hate myself but the first
time I was in a safer space sounds like
a good time I have a feeling based on
the descriptions and some of what I've
heard from folks who are at Fantastic
Fest that it's gonna be right up my
alley yeah I'm pumped I think you'll
love so I want to make sure some of our
viewers out there get to know you a
little so I wanted to go back to the
very beginning I love asking people what
was the movie or the TV show that made
you say to yourself like that's the
industry I belong and I have to do what
I just saw I think I watched Girl
Interrupted and I loved Angelina Jolie's
so much I I won I think I had was like a
big crush on her I was like oh my god
what is that and I was like awakened
part of me was and then part of it I was
just like wow that's so cool to just
dive into being that you know [ __ ] up
and and and emotionally complicated and
that being I just I found that to be
like a really attractive character and
then I had this class in high school
called films of the 90s it was like an
elective and we just watched all of
these different cool movies from the 90s
and it really I think made me think wow
this is what I really I want to do I
feel like I could teach that class yeah
shout-out to Benedict fancy my error
right there so you see that movie you
say to yourself I want to be in this
industry yeah I'm curious how did you
picture yourself as an actor at that
point near life and how much has it
differed in terms of what you've
accomplished so far
like was there a specific type of movie
that made you say like I'd be perfect
for that genre
ah I don't know I I don't know if I'm
doing like what I will I don't know I
don't know that's such a hard question I
just have always wanted to like do
something that made me feel really
uncomfortable you know what I mean I
would I just want to like do after the
I want to do something like really
hardcore you know and something that
people are gonna be like oh why did she
do that like I've always been attracted
to that kind of feeling because I'm in
my life I'm very much like a control
freak and I'm I'm you know 24 I'm
already married like I'm by the book all
the way there was like a year in my when
I was like 18 18 19 20 I was like and
then it ended but I don't know I just
like I like the challenge I think so
another thing that I like to ask with
the beginning of the Kirk's I think this
is one of the most difficult things to
achieve because I imagine when you're
first starting out you kind of want to
say yes to everything you want to get a
screen time but you also want to carve
the appropriate path and the projects
that are most meaningful and really
speak to you how do you kind of find
that balance between wanting to get the
gigs but also making sure you curate
your foam ography well when I was first
it's interesting that you should say
that because when I was first starting
out I really I could start out when I
was 16 and I really nice tarted
auditioning and in 16 I really like got
the ball rolling I really didn't want to
do Disney Channel not to [ __ ] on Disney
Channel they're great and they've
created like really successful careers
and great shows and obviously amazing
movies but just for me I was like that's
not me like that's not what I want to do
and want to do you know stuff that is
less conventional less stuff that'll
make me feel uncomfortable that make
audiences feel uncomfortable and my
manager was like please you're sixteen
one you've never done a movie you cannot
make these cut like you need to go out
for everything and I was like I don't
want to do it I don't wanna do it and
then I went out for it eventually
because I was like okay oh of course I
need to do it and I need to like you
know be less full of myself and then I
went and they were like we don't get her
and then I was like I was right they
don't get me like I don't get you know
what I mean most of the time I think
when I've felt like this isn't for me
I'm not for them which is lucky and then
there's some times where like that's for
me and then it's just not so they're
like this is for
somebody because to get some wonderful
things is there any particular audition
that was that was super tough to not get
like you thought you nailed it and it
just didn't work out for whatever reason
so many how do you overcome something
like that because everyone out there
deals with some degree of failure career
in life anything at all so it always
helps to hear how somebody else gets
past it I mean I think it gets easier
the more that it happens because like
80% of this is rejection
it's just rejection filled so you get
used to it I think but I think you have
to have a little bit of perspective like
it's a job at the end of the day it's
not I mean it doesn't feel that way to
me this is my career but you have to
have things that are more important to
you and I think the older that I've
gotten you know like building more of a
home base here and getting married and
having a I don't want to say rich social
life because that sounds ticked but is
something where it's a support system
thank you it makes you feel like oh well
that's just this thing and that's not
all of the pieces of my pie ya know what
I mean it was important to have that
that's who I am that's why I'm happy I
have that mentality about my career here
a collider when like other people in the
room right now are that support system
when we all like beat each other beat
ourselves up over things yeah but we can
always turn to each other and everybody
gets in yes help us out
Sarah and I Sarah Davis on the show we
both are very like at the end of scenes
were like oh my god I screwed that up
and I did this and I really thought I
could have done this and I thought I
could have just you know been more of
this and you know just we go back and
forth with our insecurities and I feel
like I have that with her because she's
like no you're incredible and I'm always
like obviously you're incredible and you
didn't need to do any of that and you
don't have a good view of yourself so
it's you know a little code
but it helps it's no I think it's a good
codependency I mean it's it's a
necessity to have that kind of support
around at times because I feel like it's
just in our nature as human beings to
you know pick on ourselves no and we're
all very like wrapped up in our own
experience of ourselves not even like of
what's happening of ourselves and how
other people are viewing us and once you
realize that everyone is doing the same
thing that you're doing you like well
you'd think it would shatter it more
than it does then you just go right back
to thinking of what's wrong with me you
know what I mean I feel like I have that
inner monologue with myself all the time
hi no time that's wrong with us but then
you come out a good amount of it you dip
back in you come out of it yeah
the only person or that the only thing
that ever hears that inner monologue is
my poor cat but then he looks at me like
I'm the light of his life and I'm like
no see you believe in me so I says I'll
out and do everything Dewey as in deputy
do it from scream please tell me you've
seen scream I haven't seen scream I've
seen scary movie which had a little bit
I'm actually even more curious what you
would think of spring haven't seen the
parody of scream first yeah that needs
to go to the top of your list do you
know I sauce I will watch it because I
my friend did a drew Barrymore costume
Daniel Melanie's wife did a drew
Barrymore costume for Halloween and I
was like that's so cool and I'm really
made me want to watch okay good but
scary movie
I watched as a child it was like scary
movie three I don't know but it
terrified me that's always what happens
when you're a kid it's like the first
horror movie I ever saw isn't really a
horror movie it's a horror comedy it's
killer clowns from outer space and now I
love it and a lot of veterans there's
another one to put on the list
it's absolutely delightful it's only a
matter of time before they really make
that movie yeah it's crazy it's kooky I
got enough of it Ward winning we have to
talk about impossible okay I don't want
to spoil anything for anybody out there
who hasn't actually watched the show but
just to give everybody a little bit of a
just cuz a lot of our viewership I think
is very familiar with jumper so it kind
of takes a cue from that were you aware
of jumper the movie when the script
first came your way
did you have any assumptions about doing
a YouTube show in particular well
YouTube wasn't you know what it is now
they're more established in this
streaming the scripted content streaming
field now but then I didn't know about
any of their stuff so I was like um what
I was like I don't know about that and
then I saw Doug Liman obviously he's
attached to it and I knew about jumper
before I loved the jumper movie I know
that some people critics I don't think
loved it as much but I loved it I feel
like what was that in like the mixed
zone also Doug didn't love it which is
why he ended up doing this but I thought
it was really fun
Hayden Christensen oh my god it is such
a crush on him as a child
this is a safe office to feel better but
I really loved the script which is what
it came down to I thought Henry was so
cool and weird and interesting is it
intimidating at all reading especially
the beginnings of her journey because
you know jumper is essentially a movie
where a character kind of has a
superpower and that comes with like a
glorification and a certain assumption
about what that kind of story is and
Henry in order to find out she has that
power goes through a traumatizing thing
well you know what's interesting is when
I first got the pilot the assault was
very it wasn't we reshot it so once our
showrunner lor in the front came on she
watched the pilot we should we shot the
whole pilot and she was like if I'm
gonna if I'm gonna run this show if I'm
gonna write for it this assault is gonna
stay with her for the rest of her life
and it you need to make a bigger moment
of it it needs to be shot from her
perspective and so that we can properly
move forward in her the hero's journey
so that was all her so when I got that
news I was like whew it is a bit of a
wait because you're like I really I want
to do that right that's a serious thing
yeah that is
it's quite a bit to have on your
shoulders yeah but it was good I met
with a therapist who meets with victims
of assault and I spoke to her at length
and I spoke to some people in my own
life who have been assaulted and I tried
to get as much inside you know what
that's like as I could and it's a really
meaningful representation of what it is
like for her to carry that throughout
the show so for folks out there I'm
midway through season two and the
callbacks to it there are extremely
powerful I can't remember right where
I'm at now is is like I view it as a
little bit of a make-or-break moment
that could be on the horizon for the
character she's about to do something
very important and I can't wait to get
to what that is I you know what's funny
is I can't remember anything that's
happened it's very hard for me too I
like blackout I'd do it and then I'd
like have no idea what happened I have
to go back and review and try to
remember
I can I can imagine doing something like
that especially because whether it's
that moment or many other things Henry
goes through like this just seems like a
very demanding role to me whether
whether it's all of that or just I don't
know there's something about Henry that
looks like she's always like super tense
and super stressed do you feel that when
you're playing her yeah just I mean this
must be a thing with people who are in
shows and movies like I just assume like
you were gonna have that expression that
I was going to look like her opposite
that girl weak a little bit like that
yeah yeah um listen I you know Henry is
16 and she has been assaulted doesn't
know how to deal with that is dealing
with it mostly on her own has this crazy
superpower which is [ __ ] wild if you
think about it she can't find her father
who she has this deep love and obsession
with and she thinks if I find him he's
gonna solve all my problems you know
what I mean of course she's the way that
she is you know and she's also very on
her own a lot and her two friends that
she
that she does have become her friends by
circumstance like they're thrown
together and they're not her friend
because they saw her and were like she's
great you know what I mean they were
like she's a bummer it's to be around
she's kind of an [ __ ] it's like a
very real representation about what
would happen if people like that come
together because my movie and TV brain
looks at the three of you and at all
times I'm like no be the exact support
system that you all need in this human
moment and there you know there's
personality conflicts there you guys are
all delightful though it's like the
chemistry in that little Friendship
Circle always makes me super happy I'm
gonna get there eventually the other
chemistry in the show that I think is an
absolute standout is between you and
Missy so I think there's a lot of
assumptions out there in terms of
Missy's work you look and you say oh
like I don't know like dodgeball cray
her performance in this is so so good
and you two play off each other so well
where there's a lot of you know there's
a lot of dark stuff brewing and some
troubling moments but it's almost like
the two of you can like flip a switch
and a heartbeat and go into like this
like mother-daughter slash frnd kind of
banter that I got caught up in so easily
it just seems like you guys have I don't
know the best working relationship in
the world to me we genuinely really do I
mean it's the most chemistry I've ever
had with a person and I they didn't do a
chemistry read they didn't cast us based
off of they just got very lucky I think
we got really lucky um but that's I mean
that's exactly how I feel about her I
feel really connected to her and the the
first scene in between us and in season
two where we're in the car and she's
bleeding and I'm not giving anything
away because it's in the previous when I
was sitting and when I was getting
emotional I didn't have to cuz sometimes
you've got to draw on some stuff from
your own life I didn't I felt when I was
close to her I was like oh my god I feel
like she is my real mom and I wasn't you
know crying about anything other than
her being hurt because I really do feel
I love her so much
like that thought would make re-watching
that sequence even more crushing now
like like what I want to punch I
probably will so with all of this what
do you do when you go home at the end of
the day of tough shooting to kind of
like recharge or I don't know kind of
give yourself a little boost do you know
what I've been doing this past season I
watched The Real Housewives
okay I like to really shut my mind off
in a way that like is maybe a bit
extreme because my husband came out to
Toronto with me shouldn't we shoot in a
Toronto we lived here in LA and he came
out both seasons in both seasons he was
like hey are you in there at all like I
it was no connection all cuz I just I
would go I would throw myself into work
and I would come home and I would just
like totally shut down and it's real
work for me to like pull myself out of
that and emotionally connect after I
don't know if it's how if it's how
grueling the work is or if it's the
emotional load of the show or if it's
just the hours or like I mean even being
on a set like you have to be on and
social all day and for me I'm not a
social person in that way and so when I
get home I just shut my brain off
entirely I can really understand that
mentality I don't think I fully got it
because you know sitting sitting and
watching a show or a movie it's like a
glorification of what an actor does and
it wasn't until I was in film school we
had to do a course called directing the
actor where you know we were all
directors but yeah we had to direct each
other and just to feel like what it felt
like to be directed and to not be able
to like tap like to be physically
incapable of tapping into a certain
emotion and convey it you know it was
like the first time I ever got super
caught up in my own head and I couldn't
make myself do something that I could
see other people do and knew it was
possible but I couldn't do it myself and
ever since then I feel like I've just
had more appreciation for the craft than
anything I feel that way a lot of the
time I'm like how why can I not do this
and then people will be like great and
I'll be like why why would you say that
to me everyone's out to get me and then
I
like I understand how everybody becomes
a diva you know what I mean or how the
word diva exists cuz I think it's a very
it's like a highly emotional situation
are they like really trying to be this
one thing and you never think you're
doing it
are there any scenes where it is the
opposite though where you've done
something you're like I can nailed that
like you walk away feeling so so good I
don't think I've ever been like I nailed
it but I I there are moments where I've
been like I couldn't have done anything
more than I just did which is which is I
think the most of what I'm gonna get and
it does feel good in season one at the
first day I think we ended with there's
this there's a scene where Henry like
teleports back into her room and she
cries on the floor by herself and we
shot that scene for a long time and I
was like sobbing for a long time and
that was the first time I'd really
really done that on a on a project and I
was like well I mean I I genuinely cried
like about my own [ __ ] for I mean
multiple hours and I was like oh I
couldn't have done anything more because
I was so drained I was like this feels
good I have a headache I'm dehydrated
like I generally I couldn't have done
more than what I did but I didn't feel
like ah I'm amazing you know what I mean
I wasn't like I'm an amazing actor I
just felt like that's all I could have
done and that for what it's worth all
the exhaustion it's it's well worth it
because you are so good in this before
we have to say goodbye to you I want to
do a couple Collider random questions
these are truly random because I didn't
write any of them down but it's just get
to know you thing if you could guest
star on any TV show which one would you
pick and why Buffy the Vampire Slayer
I know it's over but I it's my favorite
show of all time I would totally buy you
in that show thank you but I would like
that I would want to be Buffy but I also
wouldn't want to be Buffy cuz nobody can
do it like Sarah Michelle Gellar I would
maybe want to be faith have you ever
seen the Buffy the Vampire Slayer movie
though like we got to yes of course I
know they're both great and you never
know I feel like we never know we live
in a world where reboot reboots and
remakes
I don't want to hear I don't want it
remade admittedly as those words
dribbled out of my mouth like no no
don't don't do I think they are doing it
though I wouldn't be surprised yeah um
do you collect anything no I'm like
trying to think do I collect anything no
I don't collect anything but I'm really
weird about certain stuff like I have a
specific type of peanut butter that I
love and I don't like eating any if
you're talking my language right now
what kind of peanut butter is it it's
this brand called Maranatha and it's
really good
what's so special about it okay so the
brand is really great but the one that I
love has sugar in it okay and it's
delicious it's the crunchy version it's
very smooth it tastes like a dessert
you're great respective peanut butter is
making me think you might be on the same
page as me yes you eat peanut butter and
jelly sandwiches or just peanut butter
sandwiches just peanut butter yes are
you I was like oh god we're gonna we're
gonna go apart here just be sure peanut
butter no the jelly
ruined it ruins it it's so much better
now Augie piece of bread exactly I agree
with you all right I feel like we have
just set the rule everybody else out
there is wrong no you're yeah - an
opinion on your own no you're not
alright you are not what is the movie
you quote the most often I don't know I
don't think I quote I don't know if I
quote a movie you have an all-time
favorite I can't tell which questions
more difficult it's so yeah I don't I
really don't have I and I've never come
up with an answer to that question I
really don't have an all-time favorite
movie what about the one you frequently
watch like even if it's a holiday movie
like what it I mean Thanksgiving
Christmas or right around the corner
it's not like a it's not like an
award-winning movie but I I love it the
movie that I watched the most is the
holiday with um Cameron Diaz Kate
Winslet I probably don't watch it as
much as you but anybody making
assumptions out there about the holiday
should give it a watch because that
movie is a joy it's a joy also how dare
any of you Oh
Hey Jude Law in that movie can we just I
couldn't agree more I watched that movie
I've seen it in an embarrassing amount
of time I watched that a lot and have
you ever seen the Family Stone yeah
that's another one I love with families
a good one I love Sarah Jessica Parker
she's the whole family I love that
ensemble yeah what I love it on a
holiday on some everybody needs um Dan
in real life Oh
for whatever reason dan in real life I
understand that's become repeat viewing
for me but I understand I and I showed
it to my husband the other night and he
was like what's going on in this movie
and I was like what do you what do you
mean it's Dan in real life and he was
like why is Steve like Steve Carell
should be funny and I was like Steve
just relax
I think wants him to always be Michael
Scott isn't it frustrating when you love
a movie and you watch it with someone
and they're just like me not thinking it
hurts me a little but I think it's okay
because I'm able to manage that hurt
appropriately and it's just a sign of
how much I love movies yeah all right
I'm gonna give you two more okay what is
the background photo of your phone
it's a picture of flowers I love how
every time I ask something that they go
to grab their front
I feel so panicked I did I I mean I do
something I walk around like tapping my
pockets all the time cuz I'm convinced
it's gone yeah yeah it's like a little
thing that's that's happened over the
years so bad the last question I know
isn't it but is it bad cuz I kind of
like it I know I kind is it bad we never
saw I can whenever I want whenever
someone says I need to go away and
disconnect I'm like I need to go away to
an exotic location but I don't need to
disconnect I just need to connect more a
little bit little bit without shame last
question for you what is the most I'm
going to Direction's wedding is coming
up with this on the spot
no we I kind of do two different things
like what what is like the most recent
achievement that you kind of hold tight
and then what is the most the word is
escaping me right now what is the most
when you do something randomly you don't
plan it like asking this question right
now who something might be what's the
word we ask this question all the time
when you don't plan something what is
the most oh my god brain fart
spontaneous it's not the word we always
use though it's not on the list but
spontaneous is the same effect
spontaneous what is the most imposing
that's what the question was
okay so impulsive and your most recent
achievement impulse I get it
oh [ __ ] I got it wait I'm just kidding I
really avoid doing that joke but I've
done it more times than I can count you
and it's not accidentally the truth all
along what was the first question your
your most recent achievement and the
most impulsive thing you've done
recently I don't know if this is an
achievement but I was telling you I'm
not a very social person and I have
recently become more social and I'll let
go out okay and choose to see friends
it's a multiple times during the week
it's so easy to just sit on your couch
and watch yeah streaming stuff I have
one friend now that I talked to every
day which I didn't have before I've
never had like a best friend that's so
nice yeah it feels good
feels really good and now what's the
most impossibly maybe getting bangs I
thought you were gonna get the lighter
in my thing that question to was cutting
off most of her hair and I was it wasn't
that impulsive because I didn't now I'm
playing with them a lot
I'm like are they okay it wasn't I
wanted to get them for a while it wasn't
like oh let me get bangs this stuff is
happening but yeah they're fun to have
they're fun oh great they look great and
you can have them both ways you can have
them down you can pull now I'm like is
this the rest of my life like how am I
ever not gonna have one I love them but
too like growing them out is such a
[ __ ] you know the answer to that
question is like you need encouragement
that it's not the rest of your life I'm
not they're not asked that I know that I
think I'm stuck like this for the rest
of my life but I think I'm okay with it
yeah thanks good
I like bangs and I like impulse and I
think all of you should watch it on
YouTube seasons one and season two
please catch up Madi thank you
so much for your time today and again
huge congratulations on the show
obviously I'm a very big fan please do
not forget to watch it also like and
share this interview before you leave
and we'll see you soon